tj watt making the call to his big
brother jj come to pittsburgh come to
pittsburgh all right we'll see if that's
what happens what we're gonna do in this
segment miles simmons is gonna join us
and here he is shireen williams miles
and i are going to have a draft kind of
a an impromptu let's figure out the
possible destinations for jj watt miles
i'll let you go first shireen second me
third let's jump right into it first
pick by you most likely destination best
desktop let's just say best destination
not most likely but best destination for
jj watt
well i love that you came to me first
because you made it pretty easy for me
especially coming off of that tj watt
gif i'm going to go with pittsburgh
right i think that it makes a lot of
sense for him to go to pittsburgh to
play with both of his brothers look the
watts seemed to be very tight-knit as a
family and i think coming off of the
year that he had
coming off of what everything is right
now where you don't necessarily know
what the salary cap is going to be for
this year at this point maybe he takes a
little bit of a depressed salary to go
to pittsburgh says oh look i'm going to
have the year of my life when i'm
playing with my brothers and i'm going
to bet on myself that i'm going to play
really well and then maybe next year
when the salary cap is more the level
where we think it is because we're not
necessarily in a pandemic then i'm going
to get more money again so i think that
he could do a lot of good things in
pittsburgh if he goes there maybe not
the best chance to win but playing with
your brothers it's kind of a once in a
lifetime opportunity and i think it
would make a lot of sense for him
miles if i could i would go pittsburgh
with my first pittsburgh with my second
in pittsburgh with my third because i
think that's where he ends up as i
tweeted earlier today i think he wants
to play with his brothers
blood is thicker than gatorade maybe i
was trying to think of a cute little
folksy saying there but whatever it is i
think he's going to end up playing at
least one year with his brother and like
they think that they can win anywhere
but since you've picked pittsburgh miles
i'm going to go with the packers and
that makes sense too because it's 133
miles from his hometown
to green bay where he could play for the
packers he played at wisconsin he would
have an immediate chance to win
something we know he wants to do and
hasn't done a lot of it at houston he's
played in eight postseason games went
three and five
never passed the divisional round and
guess what they could use another pass
rusher that makes a lot of sense to me
mike that he would go to the green bay
packers yeah i agree with both of you
and those would be my first two picks i
just want to say one thing about the
steelers because the cap is going to be
an issue it does feel inevitable that
we'll see jj watt in black and gold and
it seems natural that he'd be in that
uniform it's so jarring at times to see
a player who leaves one team goes to
another and you see him in that new
uniform you're like something's not
right here i remember the first moment
we actually saw tom brady in buccaneers
colors and i even though i knew for
months we were going to see it my brain
didn't want to process it i can see jj
watt in that black helmet with the logo
on one side and and just fitting right
into what the steelers do and what they
are i worry about the salary cap
tj watts status is not not cemented long
term there and there was a weird report
a couple of weeks ago although it was
debunked by folks in pittsburgh the tj
was upset about something at the end of
the season and skipped out on something
although my understanding is that that
was a an incorrect report it just makes
you wonder is there frustration there
that he hasn't gotten his contract yet
he's put four seasons in and has yet to
be paid by the pittsburgh steelers but
when they got derrick the fullback last
year i thought they're thinking ahead to
the possibility that jj is going to be
available and so the steelers would make
a ton of sense as with the packers in
jj's home state of wisconsin
i'm gonna go with the tampa bay
buccaneers let's go jump on the the
tommy bandwagon he could be the
endowment consu replacement in tampa bay
and between wat and sue
watt and sue
i don't know
it's
just
i don't know
i yeah it's what's gonna sell a lot more
jerseys than sue not that you need to
sell jerseys or tickets now that you
have tommy but i think that if the
steelers and the packers are out of the
question i'm intrigued by the fact that
he could join the buccaneers
okay i i like the fact that you're
talking about sue in that area and i
don't know who's better either but i'll
tell you what playoff sue was a monster
and he was kind of a monster in the
super bowl too so once sue gets to that
level it's like all right i'm gonna turn
it on um the next pick i would go with
is probably the titans and i'll say it
because the titans definitely need to
improve their defense their defense was
especially bad on third down they
allowed over 50
of third down conversions to be
completed and and that is just something
that you can't do if you want to be a
real contending team so if you want to
get your pass rush better yes that could
definitely happen with jj wap but also
it would give him an opportunity to go
against houston two times a year and i
don't know how much jj watt is a
vengeful person but if it's me i don't
know i kind of would probably like to be
able to see houston two times a year and
then kind of stick it to him a little
bit so i would say the titans would be
next on my list
yeah miles i had the titans on my list
of teams too simply because mike frable
coached him was the defensive
coordinator in houston for a while and
they were last in the nfl and sacks with
19 so that does make some sense there
too i'm going to go with the ravens uh
with my next pick and he can reunite
with uh former texas defensive
coordinator and defensive line coach
anthony weaver i think he likes playing
for anthony weaver they're in need of a
pass rusher as we know matthew jadan
judon uh yannick ngoc way or free agents
derek wolf's a free agent they need some
pass rush help they seemingly have the
cap room to get him there um he'd get to
face his brothers twice a year i don't
know if he would like that part of it
mike but baltimore sounds like a a solid
destination because they also have a
chance perhaps to win immediately
you know points bet put together odds
for the next destination of jj watt and
some of the obvious teams we've
discussed are on there one team that
wasn't even listed though the
indianapolis colts and that's going to
be my next pick because if you're going
to stay in the division why not go to
the team that feels like it's the most
loaded we don't know who the
quarterback's going to be but assuming
they get somebody who is you know
befitting that great offensive line
already potent defense he just makes a
strong defense even better he's at a
point in his career where he you put him
in a rotation he doesn't have to be on
the field all the time
he's going to stay healthier that way
but if you want a team that has
routinely bedeviled the houston texans
it's the indianapolis colts and if you
want to stick it to the texans the way
brett favre wanted to stick it to the
packers the colts of the team to join
they could be the team to join but then
i think there's probably if you want to
win there could be some better options
within the conference and i will go with
here the buffalo bills because they
definitely need some help in terms of
helping their run defense they could use
some help with another pass rusher as
well but then apparently stefan diggs is
now going on the recruiting trail
because just before i got on this call
with you guys here uh stefan diggs was
tweeting that j.j watts saying just hear
me out real quick big fellas so
[Laughter]
this could be one to do it with and i
think if the chiefs want excuse me the
bills want to be able to catch the
chiefs right they have talked about guys
from their own organization brandon bean
did it so there is definitely still a
gap between where the bills are right
now where the chiefs are in the afc i
think that j.j watt could be one piece
on defense a good veteran piece that can
help you close that gap a little bit now
again how much is he going to help you
all that much i don't know based on what
his performance could be but i think it
would be fun to see him on that bill's
defense
miles i'm going to go with the seahawks
with my last pick they seemed to love x
texans they traded for dwayne brown and
davion county they don't have to make a
trade for j.j what they need a pass rush
they have no cap space as we know they
would have to cut carlos dunlop probably
to do that that would free up 14 million
dollars but
mike frankly i'm not sure that jj watt
is an upgrade on carlos dunlop so i'm
not sure that's might be where he's
headed but if you're just throwing teams
out there that have a need for pass
rushes if they could somehow figure out
a way to fit him under the cap i know
they would like to add him
yeah and and you wonder if this is going
to be the kind of move that will prompt
russell wilson to go knock on john
schneider's door and say hey why don't
we go get him i want to be involved in
personnel this guy's available let's go
get him so that's a good thought
especially if they don't bring back
dunlap sharing i'm i'm surprised because
if i would have had to guess
as to what your third pick was going to
be
i would have thought i mean we played
the sound earlier what did jj watts say
he's always going to be a texas guy now
well there isn't a team in san antonio
yet
how do you not take the dallas cowboys
demarcus lawrence has already been
lobbying on twitter for jj watt to join
the cowboys and that would be a way to
maybe stick it to the houston texans i'm
staying in the state i'm going a few
hours down the road and i am going to go
play for the dallas cowboys so i'll go
ahead and make that my pick even though
i'm surprised none of us picked the
chiefs and and let's have a conversation
about the chiefs after this i think the
cowboys make a lot of sense my concern
though is the cowboys have been paper
champions for so long i just wonder if
j.j watt is convinced that he really is
going to be within within reaching
distance of a championship by playing
for the cowboys but let's let's i want
to get your thoughts on the chiefs i'll
start with miles i you know this is a
team there
that i think could use the the help in
the rotation yes you've got chris jones
you've got frank clark but a presence
like jj watt on a team that is going to
be salty a team that's going to be
motivated a team that has an incredibly
good offense if you could get jj watt
for a bargain basement price how could
you say no to that
i would definitely not say no to that
and i think one of the interesting
things about jj watts career at this
point is is he gonna be a mercenary
somebody like chris long who toward the
end of his career just started going
places and winning rings right i mean
you saw chris long on the patriots and
then chris long goes to the eagles and
he's that pass rush specialist but he
really does make a difference and i
think when you can add somebody like
that who's a veteran presence who has
done so many good things has over 100
sacks in his career and you can add him
to a team that is already pretty much
championship ready that can do nothing
but help i think he helps the locker
room he's already familiar with tyron
matthew they've been teammates i just
think that that could be a really good
fit if that's some place where he wants
to go and he wants to say hey i'm ring
chasing at this point in my career
and miles i'm surprised when i looked it
up that he turns 32 in march it seems
like this guy's been around forever but
i think a place like kansas city would
really help him because he could be part
of the rotation he could play on third
downs only i think he played too many
snaps for the texans that where he is in
his injury plague career we know that
and mike when you look at it he had one
sack in the final eight games for the
texans this year i think he was used up
in the last five seasons he has 26 and a
half sacks and that includes the 16 in
2018 he just hasn't been as dominant as
he once was we know that he's missed 32
games over the past five seasons i just
think playing in a place like kansas
city would really benefit him from being
in that rotation and not have to be the
ever down guy to get it done down after
down after down play after play after
play mike
and we've talked so much this week about
quarterbacks who are looking to engineer
a destination boost their legacy get a
championship jj watt doesn't have to
ask for anything no trade he's already
got has his release he can go wherever
he wants the question is
who is going to want and points bet as i
mentioned earlier put together the odds
of the next destination for jjy let's
take a look at that
that list and the pittsburgh steelers to
no surprise are the team at the top of
the stack at plus
140 plus 150 it's moved a little bit i
think it was plus 140 although i may be
misremembering 140 150 they know who we
mean then we get tampa bay and green bay
at plus 400. so they're on track with
what we were thinking beyond that you
know we didn't mention the bears we
didn't mention the patriots i don't know
that
new england would be a good fit for him
after dealing with bill o'brien the rams
miles you've got familiarity with the
rams let's talk about that for a second
you know the rams have been in that
we'll go get anybody we're all in and
they don't have draft picks to use at
least not in the first round could you
see the rams making a play for jj sure i
think it would be interesting definitely
to add him to that front line i mean you
get six defensive player of the year
awards basically between him and then
aaron donald along that defensive front
now the rams do have somebody like
michael brockers they have sebastian
joseph day on that front line but they
also now are gonna have to figure out
what they're gonna do at edge rusher
leonard floyd is another free is a free
agent for them coming up in the in march
so i think it definitely could be a fit
you think about clay matthews who signed
there in 2019 eric weddle signed there
in 2019 so if you're looking at guys who
are veterans who are of that mold where
i really want to come in there and win a
championship yeah that definitely could
work and i think it would be kind of
fearsome to have both aaron donald and
jj watt across that front line
and mike i also had the bears on my list
and i actually had him third and pivoted
off of that and the reason is his wife
plays soccer for the chicago red stars
and that just seemed he they've been up
in chicago we saw a tweet not very long
ago of him it looked like he was in
chicago going out and getting pizzas so
they live up there part of the year so
that to me makes sense from that
standpoint but the reason i pivoted off
of it is that's the last thing they need
they need to spend some money on the
offensive side of the ball they don't
necessarily need another pass rusher but
to me chicago does make sense for j.j
watt it maybe doesn't make as much sense
for the bears
and one of the realities of free agency
there's football sense and there's
business sense and bringing in jj watt
really does reflect a certain amount of
business sense he will sell jerseys he
will create buzz he will be a great
ambassador for the city he'll make a
connection with the city
and and that's where you get into the
back and forth that potentially arises
when you're talking about what the owner
wants
and what the football operations wants
and it could be it could be that that
maybe one of these teams that you know
that isn't a shortlist
super bowl favorite throws the kind of
money at jj miles that that he just
can't refuse yeah if there are teams
like that i would say two would be maybe
the raiders and the browns because the
browns are supposed to have a lot of cap
room they are going to need somebody
else opposite probably of miles garrett
who can really generate that pass rush
and that's something that i think that
they want to do especially because
olivier vernon is going to be coming off
a major injury going into next year but
if you think about the raiders too i
mean they're in a place where they're
trying so hard to catch kansas city and
they desperately
desperately need to upgrade their
defense and i think if you think about
jj watt he is of that mold where he's
the football guy just somebody that
you're just sure that john gruden would
love to have around and especially
because he could maybe help bring up
those young past rushers like a max
crosby like a cleveland furl they who
have kind of struggled on the outside
especially feral i mean he's just not
necessarily lived up to that billing of
being a top five pick that you would
expect so i would not necessarily be
surprised if they dropped their hat into
that ring but trine i don't know how
really interested j.j watt would be in
any one of those teams
yeah i had the browns on my list too
mike simply because olivier vernon is
leaving the team and i think he would be
a good influence for miles garrett we
know the browns are interested in just
about any free agent that comes on the
market i think he would help their
defense mike
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports